foreign
call him on Instagram I will try I'll
try
Mike
brigandi is his name whoever typed it
before I believe you you misspelled it
foreign
let's see this
I don't live in the UK no
I live in Canada alhamdulillah I'm gonna
call him
oh he's here
he's there let me autumn
hello can you hear me
yeah I can hear you how are you doing is
it is it clear is it like good or it's
good there's a little bit of background
noise but it's a soothing
good okay
so how are you doing today
good good how are you I'm good thanks um
is it possible to turn your phone on the
side so it's landscape
perfect
so where are you at right now
my house my backyard
um
all right it's very nice view
all right thanks so
let's I think it's it's only fair that
we begin with meeting on Common Ground I
think it's a good place to start
defining definitions
um and getting all those misconceptions
out of the way so firstly I want to know
do you accept proper logical deduction
as a you know proper method or path to
truth
yes it can lead the truth yes but logic
alone without evidence without
demonstrable evidence to me is
not as valuable as science itself right
as demonstrable evidence
okay okay
um and is there a reason specifically
you would say that
well anybody can come to any logical
conclusion uh for example I can
logically conclude that the Earth is
flat without any demonstrable evidence
it might seem that it's logically the
case that the Earth is flat but it's
actually not right yeah okay I
understand that line of thinking but I
myself and this is why I wanted to get
this out of the way I wouldn't even
consider that a logical deduction I
would consider that illogical and
irrational because on what premise are
you saying the Earth is flat you know I
can't see a curvature all I see is
flatness
it's logic that's a logical conclusion
I would say that's an illogical
conclusion but how about for example
how's that it's it's illogical because
of
because you're making yourself the
measuring stick truth I actually think
if anything that's an issue with science
because it's based on induction right
um science would go no let's test to see
whether or not the Earth is flat let's
go out and see let's let's walk around
the earth and see if there is an edge to
it that's what science would do right
what you're doing is going yeah it seems
to me the Earth must be flat because I
can't see an edge to it it's logically
deductive that the Earth is flat that's
what you're doing science is the
opposite of what you're doing yeah well
I mean I wouldn't say I'm doing that I
have not done that but this is a proper
logical deduction because then then what
it what is your logical conclusion that
points to God that demonstrates that God
is even possible well I mean possibility
is different from necessity and we'll
get there we'll get there but I want to
isolate uh and really establish these
principles first so when it comes to
deduction let's say for example you have
10 centimeters of space right and you
you break every centimeter down into
smaller and smaller units right either
you can break it down infinitely
or you break it down to the lowest the
smallest unit of space which would be
the plank length right you cannot have
an infinite regression of that therefore
you know that there is a smaller
smallest unit because if you had an
infinite regression you would have an
infinite amount of space in a finite
space an infinite amount of units in a
finite space
no no there are an infinite amount of
numbers between one and two Infinity
does exist
mathematical with it mathematically but
not physically oh well again Infinity
itself is a concept
yeah but mathematics I'm saying
physically
it would be impossible well we it may
exist physically we don't know we can't
test to see if the universe is infinite
I'm not talking about the universe yeah
I'm not talking about the universe here
okay well Infinity is a true concept
right it's real it does exist
Infinity exists physically
as far as we know yes it does it it
copies this physically it could could
and does is very different right so
could you give an example of something
that is like physically infinite for
example space itself could be infinite
if the universe could be infinite could
be I'm I'm asking again I don't have any
actual evidence that there is something
yeah that is infinite but it could be
possible yeah based on the mathematics
yeah okay okay
and yeah mathematically as possible of
course but when you say for example like
you said
uh there is infinity you have to be very
clear which is why I wanted to get this
out of the way to begin with
um but deduction and this is proof that
you would have to accept deduction
because even you and like the videos you
made about the Quran in Islam you use
deduction you said that um
scientifically we've never observed or
you didn't say this on paraphrasing but
biologically humans can't live up to 150
years therefore Noah it was impossible
for Noah to live 950 years well yes okay
that's a deduction let me speak for a
second yes it is biologically impossible
for a human being to live to 950 it's
not 150 950 in the Bible or the Quran
whatever right that is biologically
impossible you know that for a fact that
it's impossible for a human being to
live that long so unless you have
anything else that determine that shows
us that it is possible well then I'm
gonna I'm going to logically assume that
that is not possible
but my point you said I'll logically
assume so deduction
yes what else would you do do you have
anything do you have a counter uh piece
of evidence that shows that people can
live that long because as far as all the
evidence we have suggests that you can't
do that
I'm not arguing whether Noah lived this
long or that long I'm I'm showing that
you accept deduction
of course yes okay okay
but based on the evidence you you are
deducting things without evidence
science is the evidence that you can't
live that long okay is that okay so yeah
sorry sorry biology biology itself
ourselves right they yeah okay yeah okay
so let's do something let's say for
example no one has ever observed
the floor of the ocean the bottom of the
ocean do you need to observe it to come
to the conclusion that the ocean has a
bottom
well we actually have observed the
bottom of the ocean but um
hypothetically if we if no one has ever
observed it you don't have to observe it
uh directly but you you do have to
observe it indirectly
by understanding that there are depths
you know there are bottoms of lakes for
example and bottoms of ponds so you can
deduct to that there is a bottom of the
ocean for example okay so let's say that
you've never seen the bottom of any body
of a water at all you can logically
deductively come to the conclusion that
the ocean has a bottom otherwise the
water wouldn't be there
so you can logically assume that yes if
you have any any acknowledgment of depth
or bottom-ness it doesn't have to be
specifically water but any kind of
understanding of bottom-ness yes you can
deduct that okay okay what is the point
here what what are you trying to get to
I'm just in this aren't we talking about
God right yeah it's all about God okay
yeah yeah the reason I wanted to get
this out of the way now is because I
wanted to meet on terms where we both
agree deduction is a valid method to
truth
um and now that we've done this because
my argument is deductive it's a
deductive one it's an ontological one it
uses first principles so we need to
deduction with evidence is is a viable
option to truth yes
but logic alone is not
because again I can say logically
anything is true without actual evidence
okay mathematics is like the first
principle right because you every with
everything you need a first principle
for example the scientific method is the
principle that is used you can't test
the tester you can't test the method you
assume it to be true right so even
induction is based on yes no the method
actually produces results and that's
what we can test yeah but how do you
know that those results
because they're coming from the method
how do you know the method is producing
true results because they correspond
with reality if I want to know if
gravity exists all I have to do is drop
this iPad a million times and I can see
that yes it's falling every single time
therefore the the results the method is
true it works yeah okay yeah so but this
presupposes certain things it
presupposes that one the universe exists
in a particular way that's a
presupposition two it doesn't it doesn't
presuppose that the Universe exists in a
particular way
uh we can observe patterns yes we can
obtain patterns we assume those patterns
are true but it's not necessarily
presupposing anything like that like
what you're saying just that there are
patterns
if if you if somebody didn't presuppose
that the Universe exists in a particular
way there would be no such thing as
science because there's no
um
there's no yes consistency like it seems
yes it seems to be that the Universe
Works in a specific pattern yes
and that is presupposed yes because
that's what the evidence shows that's
what the evidence can demonstrate and
produce
okay exactly and when it comes to the
scientific method we presuppose that
that is a valid method to truth that it
works you cannot test it if you were to
and by the way when you said that you
can drop something so let me finish let
me let me finish let me I'm getting to
that I'm getting to that if you drop
that 100 times if you drop that 100
times you're using the scientific method
so you're using the scientific method to
prove the scientific method that's
circular research no no I'm not I'm
using the scientific method to
demonstrate that gravity is possible I'm
not able to do a pattern in the universe
yeah I'm talking I'm talking I mean you
misunderstand my point I understand what
you're saying but you misunderstand my
point that the scientific method is
presupposed to work you can't prove the
method works you you assume it does
you're the the the the the evidence that
we have in front of us the phone that
you're using is evidence that science
works okay iPad everything around us
that we produced due to science is
evidence that science works and how did
you acquire that evidence
because we've used iPhones we've used
these things we've built these things
based on science science works because
we have we have results iPhones iPads
things like that exactly so we're using
the scientific method assuming it to be
true and taking those results if we use
those results as proof that the
scientific method works that's circular
reasoning
well you see what I'm getting at yes
so the evidence shows us that they were
that the scientific method Works what
else Works other than science to you
what what is a better method in science
no I'm saying that the evidence doesn't
prove the method works the method
working is presupposed look look the
results show that the method works
because the results correlate with
reality as best as we can see
and we see the reality and experience it
and understand it using
observation and the scientific method
correct yeah yes so you can't observe
the scientific method so you can't prove
it that's my point that it's are you
serious it's presumed to be true people
do science all the time in Laboratories
we can do science
happening and we can see the results
I don't I don't think you're
understanding what I'm saying you can't
test the method you can only use it and
and suppose it up uh to be true
presuppose that it works we test the
method every time we do science every
time we do science we test a method
because it
results in things that we can use in
reality it results in iPads and results
in physical things that we can use
cars are a result of science the
scientific yeah science goes behind a a
car how the engine works the tires okay
science went into that yeah let me okay
let me explain it like this because a
lot of people who love science and
science is beautiful they misunderstand
this because behind every Sciences
there's a philosophy there's a
philosophy of science and if you don't
understand the philosophy of science if
you don't understand that science is
faith that the future will behave like
the past then your understanding of the
method is flood if you don't understand
that the method is presupposed to work
and we assume it works then you if you
try and prove the method using that
method that's circular reasoning this is
why it's fallacious it doesn't make
sense and I can say the same about you
you can I can say you're just logically
assuming and you don't have any way to
test your logical assumptions I can say
this thing about you but science the
difference between you and science is
that science actually produces results
again I keep saying the same thing
because you're not understanding science
actually produces results that we can
test that we can't observe yeah yeah
falsifiability I agree but my point is
what science is predicated on cannot be
proven it's assumed to be true
that's my point and I agree I think
that's Give an example give an example
of that this these scientific method
itself
observing
yeah observations and coming to certain
conclusions and the entire method of
induction based on our observation is
assumed to work it's assumed to be true
and then we use that method because yes
because it produces results that we can
actually utilize in reality that's why
we as presuppose science works because
it worked in the past
what is so difficult to understand I I
think your your Mis I think you're
confusing the results with the method
because you can't my point you can't
solve the method the results not
circular reasoning that's Circle the
reason is listen the results damages
that the method is reliable
if you use the results from that method
that is circular reasoning
that's what I'm stating again but the
results have been produced many times
you can do this as many times as you
want give me a better way of
demonstrating this than science give me
a better method than science I'm not
saying it doesn't work I'm saying that's
pretty supposed to be true listen you
agree that we all we have is our five
senses right
that's not all we have to observe yes
okay to observe yes we have we have more
than five senses
uh to observe yes but it it depends on
what you mean in terms of what in terms
of observing the reality sight uh
hearing all these deficiences that we
have that's all we have to work with and
as far as we know science yes although
the method is presupposed it does work
it does seem to work yeah I don't I
never said it doesn't I suppose but it
seems to work and it seems to produce
things and that's why we continue to use
science we don't continue to use the
Quran or the Bible because they're
useless
okay well I'm glad we agree that science
works and the method is presupposed
because that's all I was getting at and
the five senses to observe yeah so we
also have ours yes deduction logical
deduction from first principles one plus
one equals two how do you test your
deductions true you can't that's the
point or you can test the deductions you
can you can let me finish you can test
the deduction
in certain instances like with the ocean
the bottom of the ocean and the water
you can test that but you don't need it
you don't need to you can use logical
deduction to come to that conclusion
Sound Logic let me finish let me finish
the evidence I need to finish this Mike
I'm gonna thank you
set premises and Sound Logic the
conclusion will follow every time that's
why we have our five senses for
observations but we also have our
intellect to use it logically to come to
certain conclusions there are certain
things that we may not be able to
observe that but we can deduce whether
it's based on a first principle or it's
based on observation we can still deduce
these things
okay again but science is the better
method because it actually produces
results when neurological deductions
don't okay I'm gonna introducing God
you're introducing God right I know
you're reducing God but you can't
actually show that you're demonstrate in
any possible way that God is real all
you're doing is logically saying it
saying it I'm gonna I'm gonna
demonstrate why that's actually
backwards okay okay
because firstly
one plus one equals two right that's a
pre supposed to be true
because even if you take one apple and
another apple and say one plus one
equals two you've already used
mathematical truths which are
presupposed to be true this is one this
is one addition means two these are
mathematical truths you can't prove that
but it's objectively true every time
when it comes to science you could see
every Apple you've ever observed is red
until you come across a green one and
then you come across one that's rotting
and it's almost black and so on and so
forth since the scientific method is
based on our observations and we are not
perfect it cannot produce absolute
truths in the same sense that logical
deductions can neither can you no you
cannot produce large absolutions either
because one plus one equal two as a
mathematics yes mathematics is
absolutely deduction math mathematics is
absolutely true because it's within
itself but outside of mathematics it's
just a concept it's not absolutely true
outside of mathematics
yeah what
I was gonna say so like one apple plus
one apple doesn't equal two apples it
does within mathematics it does but it's
a concept the idea of one is a concept
it's a true concept to which we yes can
observe in reality if you need to yes
but but your point is that we can't get
to Absolute truths
um
is that your point right
or science science doesn't get us absent
shoes and I agree science doesn't yeah
but neither can you just yeah just by
you presupposing God exists it does not
mean he does exist that's your
presupposition still wait sorry can you
repeat that can you repeat that
you're saying God exists right yeah
that's a presupposition basically no
it's not based on no evidence yes but
you just said that you you accept
logical deductions as a form of uh as a
method a path to truth
yes but your logical deduction of God is
not but again I actually you forgot that
I included the evidence part that's the
most important part the ability to
demonstrate that your logic is true okay
that's valuable versus just saying
whatever you agree it's valuable I agree
it's valuable I agree 100 it's valuable
but can you say that we'll never know if
one plus one equals two since we cannot
um prove it you without using
mathematical truths to begin with
again does one plus one equal to
mathematics is a concept just like the
language you're asking like is is uh
should we use and in a sentence it's
like yes it's a it's English it's a
concept mathematics is a is a language
just like English
within the language there is absolute
truth within yes of course but outside
of that it does not exist math is just a
concept it does not exist in the
universe itself it's not inherent in the
universe
just like English isn't
I think that was
a huge Shaman foreign
math is deduction math itself is
deduction
it is a form of language yes
but it's not a form of language like
English is
because we use mathematical principles
as first principles and we can logically
deduce certain things without observing
them for example one equals one is true
regardless objectively one plus one
equals two is true objectively that's a
logical deduction you come to using set
premises and Sound Logic
and it cannot be compared to something
like language
that's that's my entire point what is
the number one the number one is a
symbol
that's all it is this is symbolic
concept it's a language that humans have
invented that is I'm not talking about
I'm not talking that's like calling me
Rami and saying I'm not I'm not anything
else but Rami
I'm not like human I'm not Rami Rami is
a concept as well it's it's
identification it's an identification
calling one one concept calling one one
doesn't take away from the fact that it
is um
objectively true we can call it two we
could call it three I agree but it's
still okay so what are we arguing about
now
you're saying that uh the only way to
get to truth is by using mathematics or
things not the only way not not the only
way okay then show me just let's just
skip forward to the part where you
actually give me the evidence for your
God okay okay so but I just want to make
sure we agree that deduction is a method
a path to truth
poor one yes it's a very poor method of
truth because without evidence logic is
basically almost useless
so one plus one equals two uh can never
fully be known one plus like mathematics
is separate from logic and the fact that
it's it's a it's a mathematical proofs
right it's it's
a language that we've described using
abstract things abstract symbols that
represent physical objects in reality
that's what they yeah they represent
uh an objective truth that one equals
one
no no yes we're using it as terms yes
the number the number one is used to
present represent one iPad for example
right yes but there isn't but one does
not objectively exist in the world one
is just a constant as well I'm not
saying one objectively exists as a
physical thing but that doesn't take
away from the fact that one equals one
is objectively true
I'm not arguing that it isn't exactly
exactly so my point is if you say for
example very simple one plus one equals
two that's using set premises and Sound
Logic to come to a conclusion that
nobody can dispute regardless of
anything
because mathematics is demonstrable you
can I can have one iPad plus one iPad
you have two iPads but you've already
used a mathematical truth when you said
this is one iPad and this is another
iPad so together they're two you're
using a mathematical truth
so that would be circular reasoning that
mathematical truth that we've prescribed
in mathematics in the first place one is
represents one thing right one iPad
you can't use mathematics to prove God
Mike you can't conflate the term we use
for what it represents and that's what
you're doing
okay again you can't use mathematics to
show that God exists you can't use logic
to demonstrate that God exists you can
use those tools as ways to provide uh
maybe point to evidence that God exists
but you can't use those tools to
actually demonstrate that God exist
because they're just tools within
themselves their object will be true
within themselves
actually it doesn't but math is only
true within itself
yes
yes
so when you okay how many people are
here on the camera right now
again
I can prescribe mathematics to represent
one Rami right one might yes but but
mathematics is again is just a language
that's all we're doing we're just
prescribing language to things okay I
think this is a again a really big straw
man because mathematics I will explain
myself go ahead firstly technically
there's three mics
secondly
secondly secondly mathematics
is presupposed to be true
because we made it up but we made it up
in the first place we didn't make up
math no we didn't make math wait wait
wait you think we didn't make up math
Aristotle and all those guys do you
think they didn't make mathematics they
didn't make up mathematical truths
that one equals one they presuppose that
two equals two they didn't make they
presupposed yes because
they described it in the first place
they're describing one plus one as two a
equals true that's what they're
describing it as
yeah but they're presupposing that one
equals one two equals two these are
presuppositions that we just accept as
facts okay we're also presupposing that
uh and or Rami is a word in English
we're also presupposing that basketball
is a word in English too it doesn't make
sense to say that English is not just
logic
it is an alias because it is in the same
way
as mathematics it's a language yeah so
when you're comparing a language to a
language you could say yeah okay it's
mathematic when you're comparing like
DNA for example you could also say it's
a language but the point here is that
method deduction language is not
deduction so it's not comparable in this
Mass it's a deduction based on how we
think the universe works again one iPad
plus two plus another iPad is two iPads
it's not it's it's not based on the
universe we look at the universe in a
mathematical sense because when you say
this is one iPad you're using a
mathematical truth that mathematical
truth that one is one is is pretty
supposed to be true that's my entire
Point yes because we made it up in the
first place we we described it as true
because one iPad is one you could
demonstrate that there's one iPad okay
I'm gonna say this one more time I'll
let you respond however you want and
then we'll move on from this to the god
argument okay
one more time when you say this is one
water bottle you've used a mathematical
Truth by calling it one water bottle
so when you take another one and you say
this is the second and one plus one
equals two those are mathematical truths
you're using which makes it circular
reasoning
so you're saying mathematics is circular
no I'm not saying mathematics is
circular yes I'm saying mathematics is
pre-supposed to be true
it is presupposed as a fact I agreeing
one is is pretty supposed to be true and
you can't prove it you can't prove one
equals one you can't prove one plus one
equals two because as soon as you try to
as soon as you try to you use
mathematical truths already as soon as
you say this is one what about you've
already you've already failed that's
circular arguing because you're using
math to prove math this is one what so
you're saying mathematics is a circular
thing to use wow okay I'm no I'm saying
trying to prove mathematics
by saying this is one water bottle is
circular reasoning because the math is
something that is accepted to be
objectively true you can't prove one
plus one equals two you can't prove one
is one
what you cannot demonstrate on a piece
of paper that one is one I can
demonstrate that one iPad is one Mike as
soon as as soon as you pick something up
and say this is one pen you're using a
mathematical truth to say this is one
pen
that's circular reasoning okay because
you're using a mathematical truth to
begin let's just let's just move on all
right all right so
this is the argument all right the
moment we've been waiting for this the
argument there's three types of
existences one an impossible existence
meaning it simply cannot be for example
two mutually exclusive terms so a
married Bachelor right you can't have
someone who's married and someone who's
a bachelor be the same person right A
Squared Circle
straight contradiction you can that it's
impossible right we'll move on from that
second there's possible existences to
summarize it it could have any or all of
these three characteristics one it's
dependent
so it relies on something else to exist
to continue to exist or to be in the
first place two it could exist in
another way and now before the
determinists come and say everything's
determined we're not talking about in
the causal chain or I don't want to use
the word the term causation but in the
um plethora of possible existences we
don't mean in a chain we mean isolated
irrespective of everything else it could
exist in a different way and three it's
non-existence does not affect the rest
of existence for example if you remove
me from existence yeah this debate would
have happened Mike would be chilling
maybe reading a science book in his
backyard instead of talking to me but I
don't affect the rest of existence just
a few things so
now this is the argument there cannot be
a world of only possible existences
because that would fall into an infinite
regression of contingent things that
have no Foundation which is not
contingent now I'm going to stop there
before I move on to like the the
necessary existence part to see if
there's any contentions with this so far
so what exactly do you define by
contingent something that is contingent
do you mean in a yeah yeah the the three
I'll mention them again I know I kind of
spoke a little fast but one no no the
characteristics one it's dependent right
relies on something else two it could
exist in another way for example my hat
could be orange right instead of green
and three it's non-existence doesn't
affect the rest of existence these are
three qualifications qualities
characteristics of something that is
contingent
okay so give an example of something
that's contingent I am contingent my
beard is contingent on what
so for example my beard is contingent on
me being here right my heart's
contingent of the all the material that
it's made out of and the person that
made it right headphones same thing
everything
it's contingent to be in that
specific configuration but it's not
contingent to exist right
would these headphones exist as they are
without being in this form with in the
shape in this
they would still exist just not in that
form that
so I didn't know no matter what form it
is because then they're no longer
headphones
so what
they could they would just be particles
of something else
okay so are you saying that particles
would be the necessary existence
we don't know particles just exist I
mean they seem to be infinite they seem
to be Eternal we don't know how they got
here if they did get here but there's no
reason to think that particles needed a
cause to exist or any anything needed to
cause to exist
well I mean I didn't use the term cause
I specifically said I'm not going to use
the term cause because it's not just
causation one you know begets another
creates another something comes from
something else
um and we can we can go you know deeper
into it uh causation limitation
dependency and all of that but it's
pretty well summarized with these three
characteristics so for example
um you said let's go with the particles
thing right let's say that the particles
um are the independent infinite and
eternal necessary existence right
I don't even know what that means but
okay
okay you know how about this I'll finish
the rest of the argument to bring it all
together and then we'll go back to the
particle thing
so all right the the argument is you
cannot have just a world you can't have
a world of just possible contingent
existences because that would fall into
Infinite regression
because and I'll use causation as a
demonstration but it's not just
causation right so let's say
um
how should I go about this let's say
that a universe needs a universe before
it to exist so our universe came from
one before it that came from one before
that came one from one before back into
Infinity right it's going on at
infinitum
existence wouldn't exist because they're
all dependent on something before it
none of them would ever exist to begin
with including our universe right hold
on hold on are you completing you're
equating existence to universes is that
what you're doing I'm using the universe
as a substitute for existence but I
could say existence
and so I could say I could say let's say
existence one comes from existence two
which comes from existence three which
comes from existence four and that this
goes back at infinitum
okay go ahead yeah yeah none of them
would exist because they're all
contingent on something else
so we need to get to a point where there
is something that exists that's not
contingent because if it's not necessary
through itself if it's necessary or if
it's possible through something else
I'll put like this if everything in
existence is possible through something
else nothing would exist
I I don't even know what non-existence
even means
but okay all I know is existence I don't
know what that what anything you're
saying but you can continue
okay okay I'll wrap it up then we'll
we'll come back and kind of delve
through it a little bit so the point is
that since you can't have a world of
contingent things
you need something that is not
contingent it's not possible it's
necessary so these are the
characteristics of such an existence it
must be there must never be a time when
the necessary existence does not exist
it must be uncaused so it's not
contingent at all and it does not depend
on anything but everything that exists
ultimately depends on the necessary
existence
okay yeah so let's go back to the point
that's the full argument let's go back
to the point where
um you can't have it I don't I don't see
the correlation I didn't hear the word
god anywhere well I'm not I mean I feel
like if I just said we must have God you
would call it God of the God so I'm
saying the necessary existence and
there's more yeah they got the gaps
because nowhere did you say God I mean
the best argument can get you is that
there was maybe a cause you can get you
we're getting there let me let me talk
it doesn't say anything about the cause
you have no idea what the cause even is
are you assuming all you're doing is
assuming that the cause is God makes no
sense okay that's not what I'm doing and
I'm gonna demonstrate how okay I'm gonna
go ahead we'll go in depth
um and I wrote These down because I
thought it would come up so let's talk
about causation as one of the points
because we know that things can cause
other things uh do do things that no we
no wait let me be very clear about my
wording I never said everything that
begins to exist has a cause I said we
know things cause other things
things cause other things to change yes
but not to exist
so my my me coming from my mother didn't
cause my existence
no so I don't exist I don't exist
you stop using straw mans okay
because I'm speaking right now because
you as a Rami right that's a label but
you are just a collection of particles
that's what you really are so when you
say my mom made me exist no she didn't
what she did is she she provided one
single cell that produced you you
existed your particles existed before
your mother they existed as far as you
know for as long as we can imagine so
yes you always existed as far as we know
your particles always existed
okay let's go with that then let's go
with that so you're saying you're saying
because they're again and I I want you
to actually refute this this point
that there must be a necessary existence
and you cannot have a world of just
contingent things
I don't even know what necessary
existence means I mean all we know is
the universe as far as we know we don't
even know what is outside of the
universe if there is an outside so
I don't know what to say dude you're
just saying you're just making these
labels a necessary existence I'm giving
I'm giving specific characteristics
how do you know the characteristics
this is this is a deductive argument
for what
for the necessary existence Mike okay
how do you know this necessary existence
is real
because there are contingent existences
and you can't have a world of only
contingent existences we just went
through this I'm not paying attention on
anything my particles okay here okay so
you're saying that in essence particles
would be the necessary existence they
are the thing that does not that's not
contingent upon anything else I'm not
assuming that I'm just simply saying
there's no reason to think that we are
contingent or the particles are
contingent anything they might be okay
but there's no reason to think that okay
so for me to be here I'm contingent on
the particles that make me
for you to be here yes your contingent
on your particles okay no no not not to
exist in the first place but to be in
that room you're in yes but that doesn't
matter in the grand scheme of things you
would still exist
okay so okay firstly do I exist or do I
not exist
you exist okay thank you glad to know I
thought it was going crazy for a second
no no you're not understanding you're
not understanding what I'm saying
particles that make up you would still
exist you wouldn't exist in that room
but you would still exist in the
universe okay so I mean I wouldn't be
Romney necessarily I would be exactly I
would just be particles okay so let so
you're saying that the particles are the
necessary existence they're not
contingent upon anything they are
independent Eternal infinite so on and
so forth again you're putting words in
my mouth I'm not saying they are
necessary I'm simply saying as far as we
know there's no reason to think they are
necessary or they aren't
as you're assuming
okay let's I'm gonna go through the list
now so first is causation right actually
we could skip it if you don't even
believe in causation we'll skip it
because it's very straightforward what
I believe I know there's cause and
effect okay but that doesn't mean there
was a beginning or the existence
required something else to exist there's
changes in the universe the universe
transforms over time that's all we know
okay but to believe that you would have
to believe that particles in the
universe always existed and they are the
necessary existence they may have I
don't know nobody knows do you know okay
do you have any evidence that everything
is eternal or that God made us I don't
know not even the most famous most
prominent cosmologists know the answer
so no
Okay so I'm going to give the argument
about causation then so firstly you can
you cannot have an infinite regression
of things causing other things because
if everything needed a cause you'd have
infinite regression so that can't be the
case secondly hold on hold it could be
the case
that the universe is eternal and that
there is an infinite regression that why
can't that be the case I'm not saying
it's not I'm not saying it's not and by
the way the same would apply to your God
if God caused us to exist then something
then there must be cause for him to
cause existence see the same price
you're gone no no Mike
infinite regressive gods and gods and
gods okay that's no that's that's that's
actually a misrepresentational argument
so firstly the I'm not using the column
I'm not but the Kalam cosmological
argument is everything that begins to
exist has a cause since God did not
begin he did not have a cause he did not
need one give me an example of something
that began to exist
see this is the thing if you have the
world view that everything is an example
is something let me finish let me finish
let me finish if you hold the world view
that everything is particles then to you
nothing began to exist but since I don't
what what else is the universe magic
fairy dust this is the universe made of
fairy dust I'm not saying it's made of
fairy dust okay that's listen you're
honest you're again okay Mike
yeah go ahead I began to exist I believe
you began to exist how did you explain
how you began to exist explain that I
was I was born on August 21st 2000
before that I was not here the concept
of he was born but your particles were
not born they didn't just proof into
okay I'm okay I'm gonna give you the I'm
gonna skip to the end result then okay
so answer the question did you did you
begin to exist yesterday yes I did begin
to exist yeah how did your particles
just begin to exist I never said
particles began to exist I don't believe
I'm just particles this is why I started
by saying if you believe in just
particles so what argument is uh Magic I
never said I'm made of magic
like physically I I physically
compiled uh of yeah
I'm physically compiled of particles
okay that's cool I don't think that the
what dude what are you saying right now
you're agreeing with me you're arguing
physically okay I'm going to demonstrate
useless I'm gonna demonstrate pause
pause this is a huge straw man because
this has nothing to do with my argument
you misrepresented the entire idea of
infinite regression from contingent
things because it's predicated pause
it's predicated your argument is
predicated solely on the
um collection of particles being the
necessary existence you cannot have an
infinite regress of contingent possible
things because then existence wouldn't
exist and I'm trying to explain this to
you every time what existence is you
don't even know what existence is we can
barely observe the universe we barely
there's who knows what's out there it's
not based on observations is it's not
based on observation
but your argument I like I said you what
you just agree that we're made of
particles I I said yeah we are made of
particles I didn't say only particles I
didn't say that particles are the
necessary substance so that's a
difference see this is the thing it's
not just causation it's limitation it's
dependency it's a multitude of things if
something can exist in another way it's
not necessary if something is made of
smaller parts it's not necessary so if
you are saying that the plethora the
multitude just let me finish this point
if you are saying that the multitude of
these particles is the necessary
existence that is uncaused that is not
contingent upon anything that is
necessary not possible this is
fallacious and the reason for that is
what is the sum of all particles every
individual particle together so the
summation of the particles is predicated
on what the individual particle that's
why it's fallacious you still need an
external independent Unlimited uh
existence to that's necessary to allow
that to be why can't this sum of the
universe be just the particles why can't
that be I just explained why because the
sum of the particles is broken down into
every individual particle so it's
contingent upon every individual
particle
therefore it's fallacious to say that's
wrong with what's wrong with that why
can't the universe be contingents on
itself
just like your guns your God is an
independent thing right why can't the
universe be if it's contingent upon
itself that's just saying it's necessary
and if it's necessary if it's necessary
it cannot be comprised of smaller parts
the sum of particles why not because if
it's broken down into smaller parts then
it's contingent upon those parts
okay so what what's open with that so if
it's contingent upon those parts it's
not necessary it did not need to be and
it only exists because on itself that's
a different that's that's different oh
is it different the universe could be
exist necessary by itself
it could be the case the universe is
comprised of contingent things so what
so therefore it's made of contingent
things
so what so you're breaking the universe
down into contingent objects which makes
the universe contingent
why can't it be contingent on itself why
not
I'm not saying it can't be that's what
I'm saying just like it is right your
God is going to be yourself that's not
contingent that's nothing that's
necessary through itself the reason the
universe cannot be secretary through
itself the reason the universe cannot be
necessary through and of itself is two
main reasons one it is subject to change
anything that is subject to change for
example let's say we had me except I had
one less arm me full body two arms I
can't be necessary if I can exist in a
different way because the way I am is
not necessary
you fathom the non-existence of the
original thing if you change it so if
the universe exists in different ways
then it's original as it is is not
necessary secondly the universe is what
the universe is no you don't have a
first one there's no what do you mean
without the first one there's no need
for the universe or uh there's no reason
why the universe must be a specific way
there's no reason why do you have
another do you have do you have another
Universe to compare this one to you're
misunderstanding my point you're
misunderstanding my point listen listen
what you're saying is that that's
attention
no what you're saying is that the
Universe
um is can only be this specific way
right I never said that
okay I never said that so you're saying
the universe can be different ways right
yes
why is that an issue because if
something and that's what I was trying
to explain if something I'm sorry I'm
sorry why um
do you have another Universe to compare
this one to you to say that the Universe
could be a different way
why would I need another University
compare it to because if because your
entire argument depends on that it
depends on the fact that uh there could
be other options right isn't that what
you're saying
yes it could exist in a different way
and it's built and it's comprised of
contingent existences so that universe
as a whole in formality is contingent
upon contingent existences
okay so okay and again and now what's
the issue with that yeah what's the
issue with that it's if you have
something that's contingent upon
contingent things
and you have an infinite regress of that
then you wouldn't have existence at all
because everything's contingent on
something else because if something
isn't if everything is possible only
through something else then nothing
exists
why can't the universe be recycling over
and over the particles of the University
recycling why can't that be possible I'm
not saying it seems to be I'm not saying
it can't be I'm saying no argument's
useless because you're already that's
what you're arguing you're arguing that
that's what I'm trying to get to no I'm
not arguing that this you're
misunderstanding the entire argument
this is the issue
my argument is that you cannot have
a chain of existence of all contingent
things the reason this is an issue is if
everything is contingent on something
else then there is nothing to bring
anything into existence because for me
to exist I'm contingent on something
else for that thing to exist it's
contingent on something else infinite
regress and nothing would exist so I'm
not saying it's impossible for the
universe to be recycling itself and so
on and so forth but I'm saying it's not
the necessary existence it would still
leave an empty slot where there must be
something that is necessary through
itself the universe if it's recycling
itself in its closed system that's fine
but that doesn't make it the necessary
existence
why not why can't the universe be
recycling over and over again in the way
it is
it can be again you're completely
misrepresenting my point if you're
saying it can be then your argument is
not what you're arguing for your
argument is useless you're not you don't
understand what's okay what's my
argument what's my argument that the
Universe must be contingent to something
else and you just admitted that it
doesn't have to be no other argument I
never said it doesn't have to be
I said specifically everybody's watching
everybody's watching playback playback
he said it's possible
I said it's possible for the universe to
be recycling I never said that means
it's not contingent
that you're misunderstanding argument
completely
the universe yes you are Mike yes you
are I'll explain it I'll explain it in
depth okay good again
let's say there is a necessary existence
the necessary existence creates the
universe
in a closed system
where it's recycling itself
that's possible but you cannot say that
closed system is a necessary existence
in and through itself because anything
that's subject to change
anything that's subject to change you
must fathom
the non-existence of it and its original
form and even if you say that there's no
such thing the universe just is a bunch
of particles this is the issue the
universe as a whole I'm going to give
two examples I'll start with particles
if when you say particles they mean the
sum of all particles then the sum of all
particles is based on every individual
particle meaning the entire summation
is contingent upon every individual
particle
that is why it cannot be necessary
you're just repeating yourself again and
again it's because you're not
understanding because you're not
understanding my no entire argument
you're not understanding dude you just
said the universe could be it can't
possibly be recycling over and over
again there's no issue with that at all
yeah but it doesn't make it necessary
okay it doesn't have to be necessary
exactly by the way by the way just you
said you said before whatever subject to
change well isn't God subject to change
doesn't your God change or he's always
the same he doesn't change what about
God changes if God well he created the
universe right that's that's hinge in
itself that's not change that's not
changes in God causing something is
change is it not it's not changing
yourself that's not God changing if you
cause something you've caused a change
did you if I if I build a house I
changed
you changed the house you changed things
right yeah but that's not God changing
there's a difference between something
existing in a different way and causing
something to exist in a different way
see this is the problem you're
conflating two things that are
completely no no
you're not understanding if God changed
something if God created something or
caused something or or cause like the
Quran says he calls people to go fight
each other right or kill the
non-believers uh that means your God is
doing something if if your God sent a
message to Muhammad right that means he
caused something to change that means
he's part of the universe what that is
changing what he's part he's part of no
he's not persistence he's part of he's a
change he's part of change he's part of
the chain of existence he's part of the
chain of existence that doesn't mean he
exists in a different way
complete straw man complete straw man
that's off topic but you said that God
isn't God outside of space and time yes
so then he's existing in this chain
how can he how can he exist in this
chain I didn't say if he's outside of
time space when I say chain I mean God
makes the universe for example and then
all these things come about in the
universe God is the beginning of that
chain
but he's not within the closed system of
the universe
but he gave him a message to Muhammad
how is that not part of the universe he
sent an angel to deliver a message that
doesn't mean that God is a part of the
universe
what
you think God's not part of the universe
do you believe in God to begin with do
you believe God to begin with so are you
going to say you're an argue that God's
part of the universe I'm not saying what
a great argument you're listening
ridiculous man okay I'm not trying to be
mean okay congratulations Mike you're
good you're a good guy but uh I
appreciate it
if God gave a message to Muhammad that
means he's part of the universe no he
doesn't Okay demonstrate it please how
does that mean he's part of the universe
how how is he a part of the universe if
God came down and gave me a message that
would mean he's part of the universe God
didn't come down
he did not come down that's what we're
saying
see you can't provide an example I said
he's a message down right Muhammad is
down yes yes I explained God sent get
the message God sent an angel to deliver
the message
so that angel is part of the universe
the angel can come within the universe
yes but God is not in the universe
but God is part of the Angel is he not
uh no he's not a part of it how is he a
part of the angel
so the Angels an individual existence
the the angel is a necessary existence
it's not necessary it's possible outside
of God not necessary see man honestly
come on I like you as well but this like
you have to know that that these
arguments don't even make sense when
you're jumping back and forth between
you
haven't even gave it you haven't even
given a logical argument yet you're just
saying that everything's contingent and
therefore God exists I never said
therefore God I said therefore then
that's their existence
okay let's assume that there was a
necessary existence yeah what does that
mean about the cause
let's get to the god part now yeah let's
say you're right there is a necessary
existence how we know it's God and
specifically your God
okay okay that's a good question and by
the way it's not just about causation as
I've said many times it's not just about
causation
causation could be one but it could also
be limitation for example everything
that every limited thing that exists is
defined by its limitation
and without that limitation it wouldn't
be right for example the iPad you just
picked up
it wouldn't be if it wasn't uh defined
by those specific limitations I'll give
another example it's easy if I draw a
circle
that Circle didn't exist until I drew it
all right it's limited and it's defined
by the limitation that I gave it I'm
also limited if the thing I came from is
limited and the thing that came from
that is limited and so on and so forth
you have infinite regression again so
you need something that's unlimited at
the beginning
same thing with the cause you need
something that's uncaused okay so you're
basically saying your God is omnipotent
which is a logical is a paradox
can your God do something evil can you
God do evil
okay so when you say God can do anything
right
okay okay when you say God can do
anything
um first we have to Define what do we
mean by anything a thing is something
that is possible right so we just we
just explained that you can't have
um what was the term I use impossible
existences a squared Circle
that's not a thing so there is nothing
or there's there's no chance of doing it
because it's not even a thing to begin
with right so what do you say
being evil is possible is it not being
evil is not possible for God so then
he's not Unlimited
he's no he's limited by something
something
I'm gonna explain I'm going to explain
like this the question itself is a
contradiction the question itself is
that's like asking this man is a
bachelor when did he get married it's
like what are you talking about I can't
give a date he never got married so when
you say God is all good can he do bad
no he can't do bad because he's all good
that's a contradiction it's like asking
can God create a rock he can't lift as
soon as you say God you're describing an
all-powerful being as soon as you say
can't lift that's an impossibility and
not being able to do something that
makes you weak is not weakness
okay it's not what it is but again
unlimited means you can do anything it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if it's
logically possible or not your God can
do anything it doesn't matter what life
says something we invented any a lot of
things if you're saying that God can
only do things that are logically
possible then your God is limited by
Logic and who is limiting God by his
logic who's living in
this is why this is why it's important
to understand the philosophical Concepts
because when you say a thing what is a
thing a thing is something which is
possible God being weak God ceasing to
exist is not possible and that doesn't
make God Limited
that actually makes him so you're really
necessary so he's not unlimited that's
what omnipotence means I mean being
anything
listen Mike doing anything
entails that it's something that is
possible
a square circle is not a possible thing
it's not a thing so when we say God can
do anything it's something that is
possible saying can God make a rock that
he can't lift is a contradiction why is
that a contradiction because when you
say God you're talking an all-powerful
being when you say can't you're limiting
him that's not a possibility
and that's you're not you're not willing
to admit that the Paradox applies to
your God because you're saying that you
can do anything your question is
your question is illogical it's
self-defeating it is your question is
self-defeating you're redefining what it
means to be unlimited and saying that he
could only do things that are logically
possible so then what is so then
obviously do you agree that God is
limited by Logic I never said God is
limited by this you're misrepresenting
my entire point it's a strong man this
is a straw man I'm gonna explain why
answer the question is God limited by
Logic can you do things that are
logically impossible
do things that are logically impossible
yeah can you do that that doesn't mean
he's limited by Logic if he can't
what yes listen what it means if you
can't do something that's logically
impossible that means you're limited by
Logic Mike Mike
by the question is a fallacy your
question is a fallacy okay I'll explain
it when God when you say God you're
talking about an all-powerful being when
you say is he limited by something
that's a fallacy God who is unlimited is
he limited by something that's
fallacious
yes it is oh can you have an
all-powerful being that's so powerful
and makes itself weak that's a
contradiction that's fallacious it
doesn't make sense exactly that's why
it's a paradox to call your God
unlimited no that's why it's a paradox
to ask can he do things that make him
weak
nesses
that's the definition of a paradox
they're mutually exclusive so okay so
can you answer the question is God
limited by Logic that's a fallacious
question that's my point it doesn't make
sense it's self-defeated yes it's a yes
or no it's self-defeating
again how is it self-defeating if it's
logical
are you orange or purple one or two
orange or purple orange theological
that's logical I'm saying is God limited
by Logic that's illogical because you're
neither if I'm demanding only two two
answers purple or orange you can't give
either because you're not you're neither
okay so who created logic didn't God
create logic
when you say logic you mean
I think he cut out
I think he I think he caught out
man well I'm trying to be nice bro I'm
trying to be nice he keeps
misrepresenting my argument
for the record I did not kick him out
okay he's back
sorry about I don't know what happened
probably Wi-Fi it's okay it's okay
anyway uh so sorry if I'm if I sound
mean or something I'm not I'm not trying
to be mean I'm just passionate right
um that's fair I just want to ask you
yes who created logic did God create
logic or no or do we do we create logic
so when let's define when you say logic
you mean the means that we use as humans
uh to come to certain conclusions right
our psychological way of thinking right
so God created us with logic so if you
want to say that God created logic okay
you could say that God created us with
logic
okay so why wouldn't your God be able to
defy his own logic
we're not saying that God can't defy
the logic of a human being we're saying
that that question itself is
self-defeating it's fallacious which
means it literally means nothing it if
your God can defy logic
that humans made right that he gave us
or something
that means your God can defy logic that
perhaps we're not aware about right
he can do something you can do things
that we don't think are possible
yeah but there's a difference between
you know thinking something is
impossible right like a a worldwide
flood or a flood where waves or the size
of mountains and and you know something
that's mutually exclusive self-defeating
like God if I were to say God can't make
a married Bachelor it's not because God
is weak it's because a married Bachelor
is mutually they're mutually exclusive
so that's self-defeating I agree but I'm
not saying that I agree your God might
be limited by Logic but but I'm not
Mike I'm not answering the question you
want the way you want me to because it's
self-defeating and I've tried to
demonstrate a few times how it's
self-defeating it's a yes or no I mean
is God limited by his logic or not it's
it's not yes or no because that question
itself is self-defeating which means
it's not even a valid question it
doesn't make sense are you limited by
Logic yes or no I am limited by Logic
yeah is God is God limited by Logic when
you say God you're talking about
all-powerful being and when you say is
he limited by something that's a
self-defeating statement
so then he's not limited so then he's
unlimited so that means he can he can uh
do anything above logic you can do
anything he wants right
Mike can God do anything he wants yes or
no God can do whatever he Wills whatever
he Wills yes so so he could potentially
do things that are logically impossible
if he willed it to do it will to be
that is self-defeating
all right let's move on because you're
not answering let's move on
I mean it's a self-defeating question so
I don't know what you want me to say
do you want to get into something else
do you want to talk about anything else
well I mean we'll move on we'll move on
but I gotta go in a few minutes but uh I
got some more time
okay talk more later if you want okay
okay so
I basically gotten to the point where
I've demonstrated how a necessary
existence must exist
I haven't really heard much of a I
haven't heard much of a response or
refutation to that point it's just Why
can't the universe be that why can't
particles be that but we've basically
agreed that there must be one
no I haven't I I did not agree that
there must be one I I'm saying that
there might be one we don't know and you
don't know either just because I do know
because there must be a necessary
difference just because you're conducted
by Logic does not mean it's necessarily
true yeah
if no it's not what I want if the
premise is true and the logic is sound
the results will follow
yes and I I disputed you many times
how did you okay do it again because
you're because you're a logic assumes
that everything something began to exist
and that's not true
I never said I never said that that's
the Kalam I mentioned it but that's not
my argument this is my point I'll give
you something so then you so then you
agree that the Universe could have not
just began to adjust the universe could
have always been here do you agree it
could be Eternal yes it could be Eternal
but that that doesn't mean yeah let me
finish let me finish let me finish it
could be Eternal that doesn't make it
necessary you can have a son
that's eternal the sun's Rays would also
be eternal
but they're not the same
because the sun's Rays depend on the Sun
they're not the same so just because
it's Eternal even if it's Eternal and
infinite this does not make it necessary
the sun's raised when it depend on the
sun could they be there without the Sun
if all there was was a sun in the race
then all there is is particles right
you're just describing it as a sun but
it's just particles that were always
there in the first place light it was
always there light is a particle okay it
never lights are photons I've already
apps have always existed
and again if anyone's not answering the
question it's you
I give up I've explained many times why
the particles in summation cannot be the
necessary existence and why even if they
worked in a closed system you would
still need an independent unlimited uh
necessary existence that does not need
anything from anyone to exist that can
exist necessarily by itself
I don't see why how you got there at all
um that's the that's the issue I don't
see how you got to that because the
universe could just be the necessary
existence okay so you agree there needs
to be a necessary existence no I'm
saying the universe could be necessary
I'm not saying there must be that's what
you're saying I'm saying there could be
so there could not be it's this it's
possible that there is no necessary
existence
is that what you're saying okay this is
why and that's a contradiction by the
way because everything is
can be possible that universe is the
necessary existence yes
I'm not that's not what I asked is it
possible that there is no necessary
existence at all regardless of what it
is
is it possible I don't know but the
universe could be Eternal and necessary
it could be
Eternal and necessary are not the same
thing
okay well it doesn't matter it could be
Eternal necessary okay okay you know
I'll give you that maybe it's necessary
maybe it's not I'm trying to find out do
you agree that there must be a necessary
existence
I don't know I don't when you say the
word must I don't know like I don't know
how to demonstrate that a must a must is
a very profound word you're saying that
there must be a necessary existence yes
I don't know I don't know that there
could there could not be
okay this is why it's illogical to say
that they're it's a it's even possible
that there's no necessary existence if
everything is possible through something
else everything that exists is only
possible through something else nothing
would exist
nothing would exist if it's only
possible through something else that's
like a mom giving birth to itself
how does that chain exist
if it's all dependent if it's all
contingent how does that change exist
wouldn't the same apply to your God then
it's like your God giving birth to
itself
that doesn't make sense because we're
not saying God is is contingent or
possible we're saying God is necessary
so you're what a great how convenient it
is that you make up whatever you want
and say that that must be the necessary
distance no I'm not saying I'm not
saying the necessary existence must be
God that's what I believe and I'll get
to that but when I'm talking about the
necessary existence I'm talking about
how it is necessary why it's necessary
why it's impossible to have a world of
only contingent existences why having a
necessary existence is as it's called
necessary
there's no way to to refute that mic
that's my point yes there's no way
around that okay what's the reputation
nothing is contingent and anything else
to exist
but I just explain this we explained
this before I'm not contingent on
anything else to exist okay so are you a
summation of particles
yes yes okay that summation is
contingent upon every individual
particle yes or no
it's made up of the particles sure my
existence is dependent on my existence
yeah well that's not what I said that's
not what I said that's not that's what
you're saying you're saying my particles
is dependent on my particles yeah no I
said that the summation of all the
particles together which make up you me
the universe
can be broken down to every individual
particle and anything that is subject to
being disassembled cannot be the
necessary existence
therefore even if particles are
recycling themselves then everything is
just physical and whatever I can give
you that it doesn't matter you would
still need something that is necessary
because the particles themselves would
still be contingent
that's what I'm saying
and what's the issue with particles
being contingent on other particles
so particles are dependent on other
particles and particles are dependent on
the particles they're like dependent on
each other
yeah why can't that why is that
impossible because essentially you fall
into the same fallacy you're just
pushing it a step back so let's say
let's say I depend on you and you depend
on me right we would never exist
we would never exist to begin with
because for me to exist for me to exist
you need to exist but for you to exist I
need to exist no no no no we're not no
you're not the existence of me does not
dependent on anything to exist
I'm giving it okay fine let's forget you
and me let's say particles
particle 1 and particle two okay just to
make it simple okay let's say particle
one is dependent on particle two
particle 2 is dependent on particle one
since they're both dependent they both
could never exist because they depend on
each other
how would they come to be do does does
the the existence of this iPad depend on
my existence no it doesn't you're just
assuming that no no Mike I want to take
a step back you you said what if
particles are dependent on other
particles right
yeah which is
um which not I don't mean in terms of
existence I mean the cause and effect of
it
but that has nothing to do with
existence it's a separate issue
yeah I'm not I'm not talking about cause
and effect I'm talking about existence
yeah and
the like my existence is not there's
nothing in the universe that's
contingent uh that needs something else
to in order to exist there is nothing
like that
and what makes you say that
can you demonstrations do you have an
example of something that requires
something else to exist
well I actually gave a few examples you
just don't accept them because you think
everything's like um particles floating
around but this is my point even if
everything is particles floating around
the summation of particles is still a
contingent existence it cannot it's not
possible through itself it still needs
something else something necessary
that's my point why can't the universe
just be necessary and like we're going
in circles so because I'm I'm
I'm trying to demonstrate how I don't
know honestly anything else you want to
talk about anything else you want to
talk about before I go my phone's about
to die
damn okay well I mean we'll cut to the
chase
um
when it comes to when it comes to
necessary existence right
um I honestly don't think you've
adequately refuted the idea that
necessary existence must exist you said
maybe it's the universe maybe it's
particles I've demonstrated how that is
actually not possible that's not
feasible and that they would still be
contingent
um just not in the way of causation
because it's not just about causation
contingency is as many things
um but
let's now go to the necessary existence
if the necessary existence
is necessary it doesn't need anything
else right but we exist contingent
existences exist
now the question that that must be asked
is why or how
either
the necessary existence
willed or decided
or it was forced to
is there a third option
either a Wilt to create or of course the
universe yeah necessary resistance could
just be necessary that's it doesn't have
to have a will or uh uh it doesn't have
to have a mind it doesn't have to have a
intention it can just be the way it is I
agree it could just be the way it is but
my point is the necessary existence
exists irrespective of anything else
but we're contingent and we exist
you haven't demonstrated that we are
contingent to in order to exist
yes I have
okay so what do you contingent on in
order to exist well according to you I'm
going to take your world view because
you believe that everything's just
particles right
well yeah it's not magic it's particles
but go ahead
okay I never said it was magic honestly
what else is the universe what else is
it
I'm gonna answer the question now so if
everything is just particles then their
entire universe is what it's a summation
of particles and anything that is
subject to being disassembled cannot be
necessary it cannot be because if it can
exist in another way
then it's not necessary it can't be it
must be contingent so even if everything
is just particles that means like okay
enough in Arabic and that's it okay but
that doesn't mean it's not contingent it
still needs something that is necessary
for it to exist in a closed system yes
and you haven't demonstrated that that's
a great logical assumption
assumption that's a deduction
based on an assumption you don't have
any evidence it's based on first it's
based on first principles
what's the principle that shows you that
my existence is dependent on something
else to exist
I've just I've explained it like
multiple times the universe yeah I have
okay you know what fine well enough
disputing between me and you well
whoever is watching this side if you
have a summation of particles that that
summation whether it's finite or
infinite it's dependent it's contingent
upon the components of it which could be
broken down to every individual particle
so therefore the entirety of the
universe is contingent on
these particles
that doesn't mean that the particles
are the necessary existence because if
you take one individual particle and
remove it from existence you solve the
rest of existence if you take the
summation of particles
they're still contingent on every
individual particles no matter how you
look at it it's not necessary we're not
saying one particle is necessary we're
saying that the universe itself is
necessary we're not saying one particle
is necessary for everything else to
exist we're saying the entire universe
is necessary whatever the universe in my
definition is everything that is and
ever will be
okay and that's yeah that's a perfectly
fine definition and what I said about
the what I said about the universe even
using your world view that it's just
particles so that's impossible it's not
a world view that's what the evidence
demonstrates that we are just particles
we can literally see them and use them
and utilize them and okay okay okay so
I've used that
I'll call it a fact anything I I really
don't care I've used that fact to
demonstrate that it cannot be the
necessary existence because it itself is
still contingent
that's what I why and that's what I'm
not understanding I don't know why the
universe can't just be contingent on
itself as a whole and I don't see any
reason why there must be necessary
existence so let's move on from this uh
I gotta go but we'll talk later I I
appreciate me you having me on I really
appreciate it thanks everybody that's
watching
um we'll talk more
um and that's it anything else you want
to say
um nothing that wouldn't open up another
discussion so all right that's enough
um peace out take care of yourself
appreciate it appreciate it
foreign
I don't know
why he couldn't understand that
[Music]
I tried not to get angry at like some
low jobs
um some low blows
but
khalas
it doesn't matter to me yeah
philosophically illiterate yeah and
that's why I try to
that's why I try to um establish some
things from the beginning
I tried to establish that deduction it's
a viable method
he was hard-headed about it we finally
got to the point where we agreed
and then I said we can't I'm gonna
explain it to you guys in depth in depth
because
he didn't want to understand it so let
me explain it firstly
if everything that exists is contingent
upon something else
is a contingent existence
then nothing would exist now why is this
why would nothing exist because it would
never begin because the beginning is
contingent on something before it and
the beginning of that is to continue
something before so whatever it be so
therefore you need something that's
necessary I don't know why that's so
hard to understand you don't want to
admit it okay let's use going back and
forth by the way but whatever it is what
it is so we need something that is
necessary now what is contingent what is
dependent
causation if one thing causes another
thing that causes another thing that
causes another thing and the first thing
was caused they're all contingent they
couldn't be without another therefore
that's one definition of a possible
existence secondly if you have a
limitation for example
if I draw a circle
close enough I draw a circle
this circle didn't exist until I drew it
it didn't exist till I drew it
but I am also limited and by the way
that circle is defined by that
limitation
that circle is defined by that
limitation without that limitation of
that perimeter it wouldn't exist who
made that I did I made it yes I drew it
myself I'm very proud of myself
I drew that Circle I'm also limited what
determined my limitations
because without my limitations I
wouldn't be what determined my
limitations if something else that's
limited determine my limitations then
infinite regression again we need
something unlimited uncaused unlimited
uh what else is there
I had a I had a few more
I can go off the top but I made these
notes I'm going to use them there's
dependency if something can't exist
without something else is dependent on
something else it's contingent on
something else same thing you can't have
an infinite register on that I've
explained it many times
um next
where is it
next if it exists in another way
if something can exist in another way
then it's not necessary why is it not
necessary because it's not it doesn't
even have the necessary qualities uh let
me explain this if you can fathom
something one one brother Hadi he gave
me an example a three-headed dragon
let's say a three-headed dragon was a
necessary existence if you can cut off
one of its heads it's no longer a
three-headed dragon
it's a two-headed dragon which means a
three-headed dragon is not necessary
that's the whole point
so if the universe exists in different
ways which it does then it can't be
necessary because it can't be necessary
in and of itself through itself and the
reason it can't be necessary through
itself is because it doesn't it's not
it's not necessary in the sense that it
maintains one necessary state if you can
fathom it being different then you
fathom the non-existence of the first
for example let's say the universe
uh and we took out our sun in our galaxy
there's a universe we took out our sun
it's no longer the universe it's it's
the universe not without a son so it's
different which means it cannot be
necessary
next anything that's made of smaller
parts this is very simple the universe
is made of smaller parts it's contingent
on the smaller parts that make up the
universe this is very simple very
straightforward so if it's dependent if
it's contingent on the uh of what makes
it up to be the universe it cannot be
necessary it cannot be necessary and if
the entire universe I'm going to say
it's one last time I said a lot if the
entirety of the universe is only
particles
we're not saying as he was saying we're
not saying one particle is a necessary
existence okay I agree I agree if you
remove that one particle it changes
nothing
but if you take all the particles
together
you can break them down into individual
parts so the summation of particles is
built up of every individual particle
it's contingent upon those particles and
we just established that every
individual particle is not the necessary
existence so in its entirety it's not
necessary and it's uh and it's uh
Affinity to it it's it's Singularity
it's not necessary what do you have you
have a system a closed system of the
universe that needs something necessary
you need something necessary
there he he couldn't dispute this he
just sat there saying you know the
universe could be necessary it could be
I don't know I don't know
come on man
if you don't know then why are you here
come on let's be real it's a deductive
argument if the premises are true and
the logic is sound the results will
follow show me how the premises aren't
true show me how the logic isn't sound
that's all you have to do I was trying
to be completely nice
um which I think I did a good job being
nice alhamdulillah
but um
I got pretty pissed at some points I
tried to try to hold it in now I'm going
to move on I want to give you guys the
entirety of it
um
if this necessary existence it doesn't
need anything it exists in and of itself
it doesn't need anything
so why do we exist
we are contingent upon the necessary
existence it exists in and of itself We
Exist because
the necessary existence allows us to
exist so how did we come to be either
one it was forced or two it decided
there is no other option if it was
forced by something else that doesn't
make sense there's nothing else the
necessary existence uh cannot be tainted
by a contingent existence because if it
is then it's not necessary
it's not necessary if it could be forced
it's not necessary and if nothing else
existed what is there to push it to do
it it doesn't make sense if it's
internally forced
if it's internally forced then it cannot
exist without creating a contingent
existence meaning you can't have a
necessary existence without a contingent
existence making the necessary existence
contingent that doesn't make sense
therefore you must have a will it must
have decided
okay it has a will it doesn't have
intellect doesn't have knowledge okay
I'm going to challenge that point that
that argument that people make and I
know I'm making arguments myself here
but it comes up a lot
if it has a will then it must have
knowledge why because if it has a will
and it decides to do something
then that
instills the fact it entails the fact
that
it must have been aware of the decision
it must have been aware of the decision
and what is awareness awareness is
knowledge or perception of a situation
if not if awareness is knowledge and
perception of a situation then it has
knowledge it has perception it has
Consciousness it has a will it decided
and it intellectually created the
universe
there is no or what what argument would
you bring against that
what argument could you bring against
that
so it has a will
it has knowledge it's conscious it's
aware and they decided to create the
universe
so now I actually made a list of what we
end up with
and by the way I want to explain you can
only have one necessary existence you
can only have one because if you have
two necessary existences they're both
contingent on each other neither of them
are necessary you still have the same
problem
so we have one necessary existence
that's Eternal that's infinite that's
independent that's uncaused all things
that we have proven with this uh
deduction
foreign
existence in a particular way so it has
a will and has awareness and at the at
the same time let me say this about a
will
if you don't accept the necessary
existence has a will then you have no
way of answering the question why does
the universe exist in a particular way
rather than another way why does it
exist the way it is and not a different
way why if it wasn't a will you have no
answer to this there had to be something
to decide that
anything there's uh anytime there's
specificity something decided for
example
our DNA the way I look
is predicated on my or sorry the way I
look is predicated on my DNA my DNA was
a blueprint my DNA was a sorting Agency
for how I turn out what about the entire
universe what was the sort of agency for
that you have no answer you have no
answer if you don't have a will
therefore God has a will as well so he
created the existence in a particular
way so it has a will and because it has
a will it must be aware unconscious it
must have intelligence
and must have knowledge perception which
I just explained it must have the power
or the ability to create it must have
creative capacity and it cannot exist in
any other way it is separate from all
contingent existences and it's not
comparable to them and as Allah says
say he is God the one the one and only
God the self-sufficient and Osama in
Arabic means the one that doesn't need
anything from everyone or and doesn't
need anything from anyone but everything
that exists depends on him that's what
Osama means he does not beget nor was he
begotten and there is nothing in
existence even comparable to him the
Quran describes the necessary existence
1400 years ago
so that's what I wanted to take him
through he couldn't understand that I
don't know why but he couldn't
understand it so regardless
um I know what he's gonna do he's gonna
take certain Clips where he asks a
fallacious question
and he's gonna post it and he's gonna be
like um theist Muslim uh God believer
stumped by simple question and well uh
this entire thing's going on YouTube so
people can go watch it if they want they
could see how
um how sad he seemed
but I want to leave you guys with
something about Islam
Science is based on falsifiability
inshallah may Allah grant me you know
goodness and strength and allow me to be
a good um daddy in sha Allah yeah I
think there are many people more
qualified than me that would completely
um
you know uh
I want to use a nice word
um intellectually stump him
but regardless regardless
the Quran and Science is based on
falsifiability make a claim you could
falsify the Quran makes four claims
preservation it will be preserved
lack of contradiction there's no
contradiction in the Quran inimitability
you can't bring one chapter like it and
predictions the Quran makes predictions
the prophet sallam himself made
predictions I want to really quickly
show you guys
whoa let me put this down here
for when it comes to prophecies the
Arcane Institute has an article about
prophecies when it comes to the
inimitability of the Quran this is it's
literally three verses 10 words and it
uses like 11 rhetorical devices a
plethora and this goes in depth on it
and uh how the Quran cannot be
replicated and that that claim holds
true and then Muhammad hijab has um
preservation narrative exposed he shows
how the Quran has been preserved it's
it's very in-depth I think it's still
like it could still be beginner level
because none of like we're very uh we're
all laymen especially myself
so that's basically that
um the Quran has been preserved we have
evidence there's no contribution in the
Quran a chance anyone to bring one
um the Quran has not been replicated in
the sense that anyone uh can bring a
chapter like it and this can be actually
measured literary devices rhetorical
devices
um so on and so forth
um and the process made predictions he
made predictions that could not um be
known at his time uh for example and by
the way by the way he made multiple of
them he made a multitude of predictions
and all of them have come true and some
Scholars say there's only two that are
still unfolding now
so Professor he said there will be a
time when women are clothed but naked go
to the beach look what you see also go
to the gym look what you see where I
mean not men women men don't lower your
gays anyways
um uh the prophet I said um he said that
there will come a time or before the end
of times
um the barefooted Bedouin Arabic people
would compete in building tall towers
where's the tallest tower in the world
in Dubai which used to be a desert with
um Arabic desert dwellers so that uh
prophecy holds up as well he predicted
plagues he predicted the uh conquest of
Rome in Persia which by the way
Muslims defeating Roman Persia is like
the eskimos
um conquering like America and Russia
and there's a video that mentioned that
there's a video that mentioned that
so the proposal Islam
he's demonstrated how he is a true
prophet of Allah and Islam has
demonstrated how it's true because all
the Quran I'm going to end on this point
the only thing the Quran has to do is
prove that it's divine
if you do that everything else Falls in
place because everything is based on the
Quran the Sunnah and take the prophet is
an example is mentioned in the Quran so
we're we're good
um so that being said insha Allah I'll
take any questions if there are any any
comments and insha Allah
uh then we will end this live stream
I would like to debate you all right
your way or Yahweh tested by fire
all right
um You can message my Instagram it's
rami.ala Khalil as seen on the screen
here
um what did you want to say what did I
say Christians are here there are
Christians here to debate
um congratulations to them
yeah so I mentioned there can't be two
necessary existences
because one of the definitions of the
necessary existence is if you remove it
from
um if you remove it out of existence
then it affects the rest of existence
right so if they're both necessary then
neither of them are necessary they're
both contingent which means you still
need a necessary existence there would
be contingent upon each other they're
contingent upon
um each other so
that wouldn't hold up
I wonder what you Muslims mean by
necessary we necessary we mean that it
must exist that it can't not exist it
exists
um necessarily through itself it doesn't
need an explanation it just always was
and we need this because we can't have a
world of only possible existences Mac
I apologize if I didn't hold up
um to some of your likings
um
I it's different I don't know if I did
good or bad to be honest it's different
when you're actually in the debate I
tried to be very nice
um but uh at the end of the day I don't
think he brought anything strong he just
kind of played dumb the whole time
um
yeah
yeah I'd prefer to talk to
Jay Mike who's in here before atheist
uses her
um
host of
talk Heathen truth he then I already
forgot I feel bad but um because I don't
think he would make some of the
very sad claims and ask the very dumb
questions that Mike asked
is the hair thickness change the more
you grow it out
it depends man you got to take care of
it I've alhamdulillah I'm taking care of
my hair so it's it's pretty good now but
it used to be thinner when it was
shorter so I don't want to say I don't
want to say Court you know the
correlation causation fallacy and say
that that's why but take care of it
it's the best you could have given the
situation
as I feel like that's more insulting
than anything
let's not insult people please let's not
insult people
um
yeah exactly uh JM Drake I should start
pinning comments let's see
Christians argument is finished too uh I
don't know what you're referring to
there but I'm sure they are
let's see this turn a physical existence
is also fallacious because event X time
infinite is it possible
what do you mean event X at time
infinite isn't possible
can you elaborate on that my brain can't
comprehend
when Romney going to get married soon
it's okay it's going to be posted
inshallah
um on YouTube
foreign
how do you apply
to an atheist saying that the Quran
challenges circular reasoning fallacy no
it's not we're not saying the Quran is
from God because it's because like it's
um I don't even know how you would make
the argument to be honest but we're
saying that the Quran makes claims that
we can verify
irrespective of the Quran we're not
saying like this is circular or this is
circular reasoning
um the Quran is from God uh because it
claims to be from God
okay that's not helpful
if we say the Quran makes claims that
are verifiable external from the Quran
irrespective of the Quran then that's a
different story because we're verifying
it how
we're verifying it using external
measures which means it cannot be a
circle a circle because we're not going
back to the Quran and saying Quran is
true because Quran says so
how do you guys use to make videos we
just we bought a zoom account we get
together we hit record we chop it up
someone said that Allah is the tree in
the Quran
can we call
it's a little it's a little uh a little
abrupt
um you can message my Instagram like I
said
what if they say Allah is contingent
upon his attributes
um
that's that's basically calling him
necessary
that's basically calling him necessary
if I'm contingent on myself then I'm
just necessary
but that's not contingent upon myself
that's necessary through myself
if I'm contingent upon myself I'm not
contingent I'm necessary
so that's like I said a lot of the
questions that are asked are really
fallacious they're just meant to trick
you like sister
um Milan was saying before
don't get trapped in
um fallacious questions
because that's what he was doing when he
asked you know uh can God be limited by
Logic God is all-powerful as soon as you
ask can he be limited you've already
contradicted yourself
so it's a fallacious question
I hope to accomplish the fact that the
necessary existence must exist and that
we're describing the best basic
definition of God in the Quran
and that
um it's illogical to believe in to
disbelieve in a god type being it's
illogical to believe in a necessary
existence there's no reason to believe
in it uh deduction is a very valid form
of logic that every single human uses
every single human uses and presupposes
that is true uh and I hope to guide
people to Islam
by the will of Allah alone
it's basically saying the same thing as
a question
what do you mean it's basically saying
the same thing as a question I'm lost
now
I'll prophecies made either hap either
happened already or will happen in the
future none of his prophecies refuted
exactly and there were some like Surah
arum specified time they give a time
frame six to nine years that very well
could have not have it could not have
happened but it did
and at that time
the Romans were like basically broken
they're basically they were basically
broken
and then they ended up uh bouncing back
philosophies in Ocean either you learn
how to surf it and overcome it or allow
yourself to get drowned in the ocean
masha'allah thank you musti
for that quote by musty
you know there you know why there are so
many atheists and mostly from
non-muslims why are you going to say
Catholicism
how do you think culture and Free Will
coexist bro so Allah so what just
because Allah Wills for something to
take place he allows it to happen he
knows it's going to happen doesn't mean
that he's making us do it
if if
someone makes the argument that
if God knows what I'm going to choose
then he made me do it you've defeated
yourself when you said God knows what
I'm going to choose you've already
established that you chose it and
denying Free Will is is is really really
really
um I would say moronic If you deny free
will
um
like you can do any number of things and
you're conscious that you're doing them
but you're you're not the one who's
deciding to do it there's just like it's
just so illogical it's so illogical and
people like people take them out of
determinism so everything's determined
to happen by things that happened before
which seems to be a little more logical
um
when you put it like that
I'm like brain dead right now it seems
to be a little more logical when you put
it like that
but for us the hobby he was talking on a
podcast with Joe Rogan he mentioned that
um free will
and and determinism are like two trains
that move simultaneously they work in
conjunction they work together
but you can't say that Free Will doesn't
exist how do you deny Free Will how do
you deny that we can choose what to do
but you also can't deny determinism you
can't deny that just certain things
happen they happen once they happen that
way and that it's like Hollows that's
just the chain
um so I would say that our Free Will
exist exists but it's it's determined to
happen
our choices are determined to happen but
there still are choices I hope that
um came out right
not bad
I'm like brain dead after that uh talk
God is not necessary he could not exist
that's totally okay the universe
wouldn't have existed so what wait what
God by definition is necessary so that's
self-defeating he could not exist that's
also self-defeating because God can't
not exist that's self-defeating that's
totally okay while it's self-defeating
um the universe wouldn't have existed so
what we do exist therefore a necessary
existence
um come on man don't make a fool of
yourself
oh yeah and see this is another problem
with determinism
if someone says that everything's
determined to be and then their child
gets murdered they can't blame the
murderer they can't blame them and they
they must just say that it was
determined
I can't blame they didn't choose to do
that they didn't choose to murder my
child I can't I'm not mad at them it
just happened I don't think any
determinist would uh bring themselves to
that point they would still blame the
individual
um
I mean honestly you just have to watch
for yourself he kept kind of like
dancing around the points
misrepresenting straw Manning asking
fallacious questions and I tried to be
nice I tried to be patient
um But ultimately we didn't really get
anywhere but you could see his
um incoherence his logical incoherence
um and that's why I started by
demonstrating and by agreeing that
logical deduction is a valid method to
get the truth
um but he just he just couldn't accept
that you could see he dances around and
all this stuff
wow most atheists believe in the
Supernatural
not this one not this one
can't they also say punishing that
person that killed the child's
determined also yeah they can say that
they can say that I'm not saying they
can't I'm saying that they they can't
blame that person for doing it
but who's not going to blame the person
for for murdering their child
that's my point the concept of morality
can't exist there
objectively
determinism equals physical free will
equals metaphysical that's why atheists
can't believe in free will
that's
that's fair that's fair because I don't
I don't think people try and say
Consciousness is is just in their brain
and that's it
um I feel like well I mean I know some
people try and claim that but it's not
like it's predicated on what
people
why don't scientific atheists
the really Smart Ones professors why
don't they use logical deduction to
reason conclusions that we do
um sometimes they don't sometimes they
don't want to sometimes they don't care
sometimes people choose to be atheist
and it has nothing to do with whether
it's logical or Not Like Richard Dawkins
I don't think he cares if believing in
God is logical he just wants to make
people atheist and he's he his
dishonesty has been
um on the public record for a while
um
and scientists use deduction in science
it's used in science to come to certain
conclusions
um
and everyone uses it in everything
even Mike tried to use it he tried to
say science tells us that we can't live
to 150 therefore
Noah peace be upon Him didn't live to
950 years
that's a deduction
that's it's based on induction but still
a logical deduction you take a premise
humans can't live beyond 150 years
therefore Noah didn't
all men are more Mortal I'm a man
therefore a mortal
that's a logical argument
it's based on a premise in Sound Logic
and you come to a true conclusion
atheists are not hard people to debate
stubborn people ignorant people are hard
people to debate
but atheists are not hard to debate you
can have a very sincere atheist or you
can have a very
um ignorant uh Christian Buddhist
anything agnostic person
um and I would take the sincere atheist
over anyone
um they're all basically arguing the
same thing that you can have a universe
that exists without one single God
atheists believe in none
trinitarians I believe 100 they believe
in three and one because God cannot be
divided into three in one that they're
all God and that Jesus is fully man and
fully God and
all of that is fallacious all of his
felicious
um Hinduism they believe in one God
eternally that's broken down to many
gods that's fallacious
um so they're all basically trying to
argue the same thing that the Universe
can exist without one necessary being
that is indivisible that is uncaused and
so on and so forth so with that being
said inshallah I'm going to take one
more comment I'm gonna call it a day and
I don't think we need more people like
me I think we need more people better
than me smarter than me more
intelligible than me more coherent and
consistent than me
so may Allah produce more people like
that and make us like that I mean
that's very aggressive for a particle to
depend upon another particle he must
believe he created himself if two
particles are dependent upon each other
they would never exist it's like it's a
fallacy you're postponing the problem
but the problem is still there
so it's
uh it's fallacious so I don't know why
he didn't really make an argument
to be honest he just said what if this
what if that and made all these things
that are logically fallacious so
with that being said inshallah I'm going
to end the session has been very long
may Allah bless you all alone